let's hear people the Justice League
trailer we've all been waiting for this
Zack Snyder's round three to try to get
things right let's do this
there is a stranger who comes to this
village from the scene comes in the
window people hungry big fish comes on
the king tide I was last night
Bruce oh talk
I believe that enemy is coming the far
away I'm looking for warriors whoa
strength
it's like
I'm building an alliance to defend us
it's very important that I see this man
better ya said that like it explains why
there's a total stranger sitting in the
dark in my second favorite chair he's
gonna fight with us
probably more or less he said now look
man I don't know who you are but whoever
you're looking for
don't [ __ ] with the flash man
so you're fast that feels like an
oversimplification I'm going to go to
special abilities see I believe animus
you're coming stop right there
I mean you are just like that yeah I
need friends oh poor girl
keep this oh yeah in thinking appeal I'm
real it's useful ex-market awesome curry
fish
Wow
what a great first trailer that was oh
man dude if that is the tone of the
movie Zack Snyder I think their time's a
charm but friend Batman was the best
part of the BVS movie Ben Affleck was
great I loved that there really show he
has like an update in his personality
here for sure he's cracking jokes
there's a back and forth there's a
rhythm with the dialogue I really like
it it's cool seeing all these people
on-screen together you know like
something about it feels rather natural
actually you know as opposed to being
like oh I want to see a separate flash
movie I want to see a separate this
movie this movie first and then see
Justice League something about this is
like you know what I'm totally on board
for it the way it shot looks great some
of it looks like it was shot with IMAX
cameras just based off the the quality
and the imagery of it I like this
venture of like Batman going around
approaching all these heroes and trying
to recruit them to be part of this
Justice League I've seen Batman as kind
of that human lead of this team of
superheroes because that's what I want
to see how this movie pulls off well
even though Batman is just the human
being he's the one with you know the
special fighting abilities doesn't have
any superpowers he's somehow going to be
leading a bunch of these metahumans I
want to see exactly what it is of why
they choose to be led by Batman I really
like to show the flash and seeing this
Barry Allen interpretations closing
clearly a lot more of a loner I thought
that scene between him and Bruce Wayne
was great I mean the costume of Flash is
a very like it's really out there it
kind of looks like to me when uh you
know when the Power Rangers have the
show and then the first Mighty Morphin
Power Rangers movie came out of the
updated the suits that's kind of what
his flash looks like to me I guess if I
had a concern was there was a lot of
like humor in this read a lot of humor a
lot of fun in the trailer which is great
which is what I want from this movie I'm
just a little worried that Zack Snyder
took a lot of criticism in about BBS's
tone and it'd been really dark and
Graham
gloomy I hope he doesn't go to extreme
with the humor because this does look
like a fun movie to some of all these
guys together but let's face it Man of
Steel and bbs have been setting up a
world that's supposed to be really dark
and epic and I know this is a different
story but if you're getting the Justice
League together they better be taking on
something that is truly like this is
epic
regardless I think it's going to be cool
man just seeing all those different
kinds of powers working together you
know I think a lot of people were let
down with bbs said you know Batman
Superman well you got to fight for a
little bit but I feel like this movie
we're gonna so many heroes you're gonna
get a whole showcase of a bunch of cool
powers Aquaman looks [ __ ] cool I love
how he's not like what the CW try doing
when they had a Aquaman pilot
I think Jason Momoa yeah it's gonna be
really cool like how Superman wasn't in
this trailer because we're really
getting a chance to show Casey's other
heroes the cyborg suit I feel like this
is still in early trailer they're still
filming Justice League I think the
cyborg suit will improve over time I
mean I could see people having a concern
about the way it looks right now being
like very CG but I think over time it'll
probably get better something tells me
the way they're gonna use the flash is
kind of like how they use spider-man in
civil war which isn't a problem I mean
because in terms of personality they're
kind of similar bold Doric suit got you
know this mutated power that was you
know an accident or was it BIA if the
movies like this I'm Way onboard for a
man regardless of whatever flaws I see
with it if it can deliver on this really
fun superhero interaction badass you
know epic peace then okay that's that's
all I really care about I seems like all
the actors are working really well yeah
I'm I'm pretty stoked for this film this
is gonna be [ __ ] sweet don't let me
down Zach don't let me down please not
again
don't stop stop doing it there's more
comic-con trailers that have been
released so I got to get to it meantime
subscribe today become rejected if you
want to you could follow me on social
networks
check out Tyrone Magnus's channel in
case you haven't heard of him he has
half the amount of subscribers
I have so check them out